good afternoon cs19 how are you guys
doing
today fantastic I you guys know this but
it's our penultimate class we have class
today we have a fun little lecture on
Wednesday and then that's it for
lectures in CS
109 I can't believe we're at that part
it feels like just yesterday we were
starting and we're like hey let's talk
about probabilities and we were doing
counting oh what good times
uh we have a very fun celebratory
lecture today uh we're at that part of
the quarter where these aren't things
that will be on the exam but it's also a
really fun chance for me to just talk
about what I think is interesting and
part of the future of probability and I
have a novel lecture for you guys one
I've not given before uh and one that
I'm really excited to give so I was
thinking about what should we talk about
and there's all these fun things to talk
about I was like oh I can talk about
like kale Divergence or I could talk
about bounds uh and then something
happened last Thursday that's really
worth talking about as you might have
heard there was a a a new release of
this large language model called GPT
just quickly has anyone ever heard of
this okay it seems like something worth
talking about uh interestingly it
coincides this last week was the world's
biggest AI conference in fact uh we had
a couple papers there I decided to stay
because I wanted to hang out with you
guys I got sick a couple times this
court and I just wanted to chill with my
CS 109 fam but um that's why you're
seeing so much happening in the world of
AI and I thought long and hard about I
just thought it'd be so neat for you
guys to learn some of the the
probability behind some of the the
biggest movers and shakers of today so
in today's class we're going to learn
about how Dolly Works how gpt3 works and
if we have time I can tell you a little
about some of my most recent probability
work if you guys find that interesting
you want to do it so it's it's also
going to be on the board so I I practice
and everything we're going to try and do
this on the board we're get rid the
screen in a second but not quite yet
because before we jump into thinking
about the wonderful ideas Behind These
algorithms that maybe are going to have
a rather profound impact let's just play
a little bit so if you haven't seen GPT
it's a pretty simple API you can write
text and it will produce text so for
example here I wrote write a
thought-provoking poem that explains the
difference between maximum likelihood
parameter estimation and map parameter
estimation but it should be sung by a
pirate as a sea shanty so it says IE
land lovers listen to me as I sing of
parameter estimation of Maximum
likelihood in map you see two approaches
both with their own
reputation uh maximum likelihood it
seeks to maximize the probability the
data that's seen map adds a prior to
regularize and balance this trade-off
between bias and precision I feel like I
got it to be more pirate other times but
you can be like okay be more pirate how
do you even spell pirate is that
it oh man IE scurvy dogs lending near to
the tail I spin a and
um this is behind the scenes a machine
learning Model A little bit like we've
learned so that's one of the things
we're going to talk about today like
what's going on with this model and what
are the great ideas behind it what's the
difference between what we've learned in
CS 109 and the techn behind GPT but
we're also um going to talk about a
different model that might seem pretty
separate but there is similar ideas that
go on behind the scenes um and this one
doesn't produce text but instead it
produces images so I said a photo of a
beautiful Coast Live Oak these aren't
real photos they don't exist they were
just generated uh and you guys have
probably seen this before I'm just
trying to catch everyone up uh and
before we go to the
board there's just one more picture that
I want you guys to see before we go in
there because I'm going to at some point
refer to gaussian noise and you need to
have a visualization to go with it so
this is a picture with no noise and this
is a picture with some gaussian noise
and when I say some Galaxy noise notice
how it looks or a little bit
distorted every single Pixel has its
original value but we've added some
gaussian sample into the pixels in this
case it's on both the red or all red
green and blue uh channels this is with
a little bit of gaussian noise and this
is with a ton of gaussian noise you
can't even see the dog
anymore okay questions comments thoughts
before we jump into
this
okay okay let's make that screen go up
let's get lights all on as bright as we
can get it in this Nvidia
[Music]
Auditorium okay
so this is our road map we're going to
start with thinking about that second
algorithm the one that can produce trees
and it's a really interesting story and
did you know it actually took place at
Stanford like the great idea behind how
you can create images from neural
networks was a simple idea that happened
here not too long ago uh by a fellow
called Josh a soul
dixin okay so where should we start
maybe we could start by building a
little bit of a a road map and I want to
put it here in the center I want to talk
about the three models we should have in
our minds one model is what you're doing
for homework the second model is going
to be this dolly and the third model is
going to be GPT and on some level they
have a lot in common they all have a big
neural network well maybe yours has a
logistic regression but we're going to
think of them all as black boxes so if
we start with your algorithm so this is
like your P set 6
you built a little machine learning
algorithm and the Machine learning
algorithm takes
features which come as a list and it
produces a prediction Y which is an
element of 01 which is a really fancy
way of saying you built an algorithm
that could take some inputs and it
predicts out either a 0 one binary
prediction but we also want to add in do
e
here and Dolly does something different
it's also a neural network but we're
going to be making Dolly tree Style and
what Dolly tree does is it doesn't take
any inputs but every single time you run
this neural network it's going to
produce not a z one but it's going to
produce an image and our version is
always going to be an image of a tree so
let's get out our blue
marker and let's draw ourselves a little
bit of a tree
woohoo what you guys think not quite
Dolly but it's an all right drawing
right uh and then the final neural
network we're going to think about is
going to be
GPT and GPT takes in some texts like
I let's say you wrote I
love
uh and you throw it into the
model and it produces more text so let's
say
cs19 uh and
pancakes okay so that's our goal let's
see if we can understand these three now
hopefully you're understanding your own
problem set six so maybe we could start
by jumping into thinking about how this
dolly model works
can I start with
just asking you to come up with it
because there is a history here in this
task of running a neural network and
having it produce an image there's been
a long history of cool creative ideas
one creative idea that's no longer used
is you'd have two different neural
networks one neural network would create
images and the other neural network
would try and decide was this image
produced by a computer or was it
produced or is it an actual image from
the internet and these two competing
neural networks would train against each
other and eventually one of them would
get really really good at producing
images that would trick the other one
that was a great idea but as I said
Stanford not too long ago someone had
another great idea that changed the game
it's a great IDE that you're going to
understand deeply by the end of today's
class but I wanted to just give you guys
an idea to play come up with your wild
ideas just make up a way like if I said
you had to create a neural network
that's going to generate a picture of a
tree
how would you do it and some of the
questions you can ask yourself are what
data would I
use and then what would I do with the
data you know how you imagine somebody
gives you a big neural network how could
you set the parameters to that neural
network with some
data have a moment just be playful make
up ideas say something Sly be like I'll
send my neural network to a pirate who
knows so much about maximum likelihood
estimation that they'll figure out all
the prameters have a good time think
about it for a second before we jump
into what is the great idea behind dolly
okay talk to the person next to you and
I'll take a moment and practice my tree
drawing
e
okay
no expectations but there's a small
chance that we'll just like totally
revolutionize the world because like
this is such an open
field okay let's hear them good ideas
bad ideas funny ideas we'll take them
all okay what's your thoughts so for
what I would do is I was like like for
trees I'd scrape Google find like punch
images of trees um and then have do like
create a bunch of images and see which
one most closely matches the data set of
trees okay scrape
Google produce an
image and then the loss can be something
like distance to closest
tree
great fantastic okay yes an idea can I
make a network to identify trees and
then in some sense run it in reverse oh
okay so we're going to have like a tree
Network kind of like ours over here you
put in a picture and either says tree or
not but we're going to then run it in
reverse and we're going to say okay
you're a tree mess with my pixels oh I
like it reverse
classification
image or predictor
sorry
okay yes one more idea so maybe you
produce like three images one of the red
pixels green pixels and blue pixels and
so you kind of have multiple uh variable
outputs and then for each of those
outputs you have
256 like values that could be and so you
take all the pictures in that you
scraped from Google and then evaluate
what's the probability that in a picture
of a tree this particular pixel has this
particular level oh okay so you said a
lot of good things like one is when
we're making this picture we're going to
have to not just output a z one but we
have to Output the pixel values that's
going to mean the red green and blue
pixel values so that's going to be our
task um and then you said you know we
could set it up so that we say like the
most likely pixel like the pixel that's
most likely uh given what we've seen
okay um okay great so we're going to
have to
predict predict pixel values
awesome uh and we want maybe like the
most
likely given
tree okay these are all very very good
ideas
shall we go into because it's the beauty
of what goes behind dolly is that it's
when you see it you'll be like
oh okay let's get behind the probability
but I can appreciate that that works now
one of the things that's complicated
about the world is you've got all these
images but on Google say not all of them
have labels you can get lots and lots
and lots of pictures some of them might
have um labels that say what they are
but some of them
won't and there is this interesting
idea you could take any image picture of
a tree and here's something you could do
to it we'll explain why you may want to
do that but here's something you can do
at the moment it's a little bit
unmotivated take your
picture and one of the things you could
do is you could break your picture and
one of the ways you could break your
picture is you could can add in some
noise and let's say you chose gaussian
noise yeah that's kind of a pretty
reasonable thing to do so I'm going to
add in
20%
noise and my 20% noise maybe like you
know one in five
pixels I can add
in some gaussian noise so to give you an
idea of what that looks like if we
zoomed into some
pixel pretend for a moment that pixel
all our pictures are black and white
this is the black and
white black and
white or like The Artsy version imagine
every pixel is black and white that
makes it a little bit easier we don't
have to think about red green and blue
it's just that if you zoomed into any
pixel of a
tree if you looked at a pixel it would
just have a number and let's say those
numbers are between 0 and one so let's
say this is like a
0.5 when we add in gy noise here's what
I mean you know for some of these pixels
we're going to add in a random sample
from a gaussian and we could choose any
gaussian but let's say we chose a pretty
reasonable Gan that has like a mean of
zero and some sort of variance right and
so maybe when you sampled from this Gan
you got like a
0.1 so then the resulting pixel value is
0.6 so when I say adding Gan noise it's
something that you guys could do right
now like you could pull up a computer
and if I gave you a pixel value you
could do hey scipi sample from a
gaussian uh with a particular mean and a
particular
variance uh and then add that to my old
pixel
value and you could do this you could
then take this image and you know what
you could do You' be like not noisy
enough I'm going to add a little bit
more noise so you can say like I want
something with 40% and then
eventually you could keep going
until you've just got the world's
noisiest
image so you know we could add 20% noise
and we could add another 20%
noise and now it's just starting to look
pretty noisy and eventually when you get
to 100%
noise everything just looks like a
random value from our gaussian and you
just can't see any tree
anymore I haven't described any neural
network there's not NE Network here it's
just a way that you could take all these
gigantic tons of images from the
internet and you could start to
manipulate them but there's this growing
mystery which is why would anyone want
to do that to your poor images like
you're making them harder to see like
why is that a useful
thing do you guys want to try and think
about it like I've left this like
tantalizing
clue
just reflect on it what could you do
with
this CU I say like when I say this is
like a million-dollar question I feel
like the person who figured this out is
now one of the lead researchers at
Google so probably was worth like a
million dollars for the person who did
figure it
out yeah probably Jesus what a
time well you could do this to a lot of
images and why would that be
nice okay an idea I think it's very
similar to what say because you're
starting with the
outcome uh so you know the outcome that
you adding the tees that separate it so
you're constantly so it's conditioned on
the outcome so constantly adding noise
you condition
you such a way that it keeps learning
how the outcome should look so that
Unity can still work yes you on to
something that is really really in the
right direction so yes we're going in
the right
direction it has this relationship
between the outcome the cleaner image
and a noiser
image yeah maybe you could de blur the
blurry images to create different trees
yeah that's it this is the first great
idea so the first great idea that kind
of changed everything about image
generation
is we could build a little neural
network and its job is pretty simple it
doesn't have to do any complicated
predictions so we're going to call this
idea number
one and idea number one is we're going
to build a neural network it will take
in an image and that image is going to
be of a
tree and it's going to have some some
noise in
it let's try and recreate that image as
well as we can and we're going to build
a little neural network and this little
neural
network when it's done it will
produce a picture that has removed 20%
of the noise so could you make this data
set could you make your training and
test
set yeah you can make yourself a big one
take all of Google take all the images
you've got add in noise and then you can
feed it into your neural network you say
here's the noisy version can you predict
an image and then I'll see how good a
job you are at removing the galoian
noise but that doesn't generate a whole
tree that just removes some noise so how
could you generate a tree with like
this well you start here Generate random
samples from a gaussian for every pixel
then run that completely noisy version
through your neural network you'll end
up with something with 80% noise take
the result put it through your neural
network again you'll end up with
something 60% noise put it through your
neural network again you have 40% noise
and you keep going and eventually it's
got a tree what if you wanted a
different tree you're like that's not
pretty enough I want a new one you just
start with different random noise if you
create different random noise you put in
like this completely noisy image through
your neural network and it'll try and
remove noise in a way that'll make it
look more like a tree and you repeat
this five times and you'll have a
picture of a tree okay questions yes in
this example does the Black Box is that
strictly
just step or do we
have one from going to 100 to 80 one
from going from 80 to 60 kind of
incrementally like that just one
box now one of the things I there's I'm
going to try and give you guys the great
ideas there are some small details that
are helpful I think this black box also
takes in which Step you're
on as one of its X's one of its features
uh but that as I said that's not the
great idea and if you got rid of that it
would probably be just fine yeah just
one box and they call that box
Dolly
yes is it removing like just random 20%
noise or is it more sophisticated than
that like how does IT training part work
like how's it getting feedback so we'll
talk about in mathematical detail I
promise cuz you guys could you guys
actually you're totally ready to
understand all the mathematical
sophistication of precisely what it's
doing but let me give you the big
picture first it has both of these
images how because it generated them
right and so it puts in one and actually
realistically you know you end up with
your predicted one and then there's the
true image of the tree and maybe the
true image of the tree is slightly
different because when your neural
network tried to make a tree it didn't
get it perfect oh all the colors you
guys this is such an enjoyable marker
experience so maybe you know when you
made your prediction you got it slightly
wrong and when I say slightly wrong what
do I mean well we know what the truth
is right we had the clean image and then
we added the noise ourselves so we have
the
input and we have the truth and then we
can see your prediction we can be like
how good is that prediction now you as
as I promised not only do I want to
explain this to you I just want to give
you the level of sophistication that you
are ready for in CS 109 we'll talk about
that detail but let's get that big
picture first also I want to explain
myself pedagogically I want to draw on
the board for lots of reasons and one of
the goals is to slow myself down um and
so that we can keep it all up on the
board so you can see the big picture as
it unfolds plus it's kind of fun for me
yeah question if we wanted to do like
the full Dolly so not just making trees
but making whatever would be like tret
to deblur images in general and then
instead of using completely random noise
like blur tree or something else so it's
actually pretty simple I'm going to
remove that detail so we can just focus
on the great idea but the simple idea is
you also insert text so you say this is
an oak
tree whatever the prompt the user gave
you and that text could help it guide
its de noising uh now when we understand
GPT we'll have a better sense of how you
could do that and until we talk about
GPT let's just assume that all it does
is make some trees but it's actually a
pretty small addition to make it also be
guided okay question could you explain a
little bit more of the intuition behind
um like the benefits and drawbacks of
running it um like five times um versus
just like a neural network would say
like five times as many layers oh that's
such a good
one well the the question is why do it
five times instead of just going all the
way so I actually used to take and I
used to live in San Francisco together
and our Labs were right next to each
other and Stafford you're like hey Chris
why don't you invent you know diffusion
and I'm like that's not important right
now um and you know I I guess I was
hanging out with him we get on the couch
we were writing a paper together around
the same time so he was telling me a
little about it and
honestly it didn't work he just tried to
do it all at once and it wasn't
successful but if you did step by step
it seemed to be a little bit easier um
and there is a little bit of a art form
to some of this stuff and I I don't
think there's a deep theoretical reason
why putting it through five times is
better than making five times bigger
model I will say this
though at the time when he was a
researcher he had access to a pretty big
computer but we're going to talk about
this in a second you know one of the
other things that's happened is scale um
you know Dolly is trained on massive
super computers which maybe that means
that in the new version of Dolly they
could go straight uh it might have just
been the constraint of his
computer good question why do
20% yes this is kind random but is Dolly
like open source does it continue to
train every time people use it and get
better um not open source and it does
get better as people use it so I mean
this is such an interesting ethical
issue um so these models are expensive
they cost about half a billion dollars
to train and there's only a few
companies in the world who have access
to them and I think they're trying to
figure out what this means monetarily as
part of it but you know what they said
they said this stuff's too powerful we
can't just give it away and they're not
completely wrong you know like on some
level there's probably some version of
GPT that maybe shouldn't be out there in
the wild people could use it in really
nefarious ways uh but that's what they
said but it's it's hard to ignore that
the value of these things even though
they cost a billion dollars to train
they might be worth trillions of dollars
to whoever can figure out the smartest
one so that's such a good
question
okay yeah question so are we starting
with like a blurred image of another
tree or just a blurred image that can
become anything good question when you
start you start with just a blurred
image so if I give you a fully trained
Dolly here's what you would do you would
create the size of the tree you want and
for every single Pixel you just sample
from a gaussian its value would be
sample from a gaan now if you want to
get a little more detailed there would
be a red green and blue but just
assuming it's black and white every
single Pixel will just be sampled from a
gan so you look at at the beginning and
it just looks like static on your TV but
then you put it through our model once
and starts to look a little bit less
like static the tree it looks like will
be defined by whatever random noise you
started with like that seed is where
this oh that's so beautiful it's the
seeds where the the tree sprouts from
you see what I did there not important
and then you you run it five times and
then you have your fully grown tree and
you're like oh we went through so much
together yes well is there like one
reference picture that the system is
trying to make it look like or is it
just so this is one of like the trillion
images that found on the internet one of
the secrets behind all this is that the
internet has a lot of data so they'll do
this once for this tree and then they'll
do it for the next tree and then the
next tree and the next tree and we'll
get every tree we get in fact there's so
many trees on the internet it often
won't look at the same tree twice like
once it's done it can just put it away
now there are different training schemes
I don't have that many tree pictures I
would probably use trees multiple times
okay so yes um what's the advantage of
using random noise as opposed to just
white
pixeles good question if you start with
white pixels you would always get the
same tree every time you ran it um
and I suppose if
you the idea here of like trying to
figure out where the noise is I think
one of the well you know what that's a
cool idea I'm just going with that's a
cool idea so one of the things we could
have done is you could have taken your
tree and you could have just like
whiteed it out every single like 20% of
the pixels and then white out 20% more
and then your job is to fill in the 20%
that sounds really good but certainly
you have this problem that you'll always
produce the same tree why would you
always well one of the reasons you get
different trees is because the noise is
different each time like every time you
create your image it starts with
different noise like when you're in the
generation phase um but if you always
start with the exact same seed it'll you
know when it removes it 20% there's
nothing about this that is stochastic in
nature the stochasticity the fact that
you get different trees starts with the
fact that you created a different seed
but I like that and you know we should
try that out an idea the D noising model
uh like is it just ran on the entire
image or does it only like d noise like
20% of the Piel each time well it's run
on the entire image and it tries to do
noise 20% but
we're just at the start of things you
know people are trying to use us in
different ways you can imagine this is a
foundation upon which you guys could
build some cool ideas and one of the
cool ideas is you know maybe we want to
just fill in specific pixels you know
maybe we just want to remove this Branch
or there's lots of neat things that you
could do on top of this
technology okay one more question then
I'm actually going to tell you there is
an even better idea than
this is the variance of the gausa noise
chosen to ensure that the training
propagates through the
network there's a lot of art form I'd
say that's not a closed discussion so
people choose variant in lots of
different ways diffusion actually comes
from a physics idea like this this idea
of removing gaussian noise has existed a
long time in the world of physics and
they've been very thoughtful about how
they choose variances for today's
example we're just going to use constant
variance uh but if you read the uh the
original diffusion model one you can see
that they're changing noise in
intentional ways uh throughout the
training process though again it would
have worked just fine if they
hadn't okay now this turned out to still
be a hard problem what have we talked
about so far we've talked about the
architecture we've talked about how you
can get data so at this moment if I give
you a fully trained Dolly you could use
it you could put in noise and you could
get progressively better images what I
haven't told you is if I gave you an
untrained Dolly how you could do the
training yourself and one of the reasons
is that it's a little bit hard to think
about about the likelihood like what's
the maximum likelihood of an image give
another
image I don't know some people could
have figured things out there's like
cool ideas like an elbow lower bound uh
loss that was fine but somebody realized
hey there's a slightly easier problem
and it's very easy to think about the
probability and really first principle
ways if we solve this easier problem did
you guys know there's an even easier
problem want to hear about it
okay here's how it
goes same starting point the starting
point is still going to be you have a
picture of tree with some noise and you
want to denoise
it got to keep the noise consistently
red I like this Christmas theme going
on and this
time the output it's not going to be a
tree you're like what is not going to be
a tree I thought we were making trees
here no pal we're no longer in the tree
making business we're now in the noise
prediction business so this time we're
not going to predict trees at all
instead we're going to say if you gave
me this tree instead of predicting the
tree without noise I'll predict the tree
the
noise what would you guys do with
that if I said here was my input I
predict that this is the noise
noise could you turn that into a
tree I see some
nodding just like division okay an idea
somebody's got this somebody's thinking
it yeah in the back oh like taking the
input and subtracting the noise exactly
if I gave you an image and you predicted
where the noise was and this noise could
be positive or negative and let's say
you predicted positive negative values
you could just subtract you could take
this image subtract out and then you
should be left with the unno image so it
turns out that these two problems
somebody realized were the same and this
problem was a much easier and B much
easier to think about probabilistically
CU we still have this task of how could
we train this this
puppy so you could have predicted your
noise and then I know exactly where I
put the noise let's say you for gotten
that
one and now we have to think about
what's the
likelihood of the True Image given what
we predicted so a lot like maximum
likelihood
estimation now what I'm going to tell
you is going to extend to the whole
image but can we just jump into one
pixel for a hot second if we just jumped
into one
pixel let's see if we can get that up
there if we jumped into one
pixel you could imagine that if you
looked at say this pixel over
here you could have two numbers we have
like you
know y hat and I'm going to be a little
clear that y hat is a result of the
neural network so I'm going to say that
it was a function of the parameters just
like the output of a neural network was
a function of its parameters and let's
say y
hat was
0 let's say the true one is 6 let's say
y hat is
0.5 and the true
y the true amount or actually we're
predicting the noise sorry the true
noise is
0.1 and let's say you predicted a
point2 so at this pixel you made a
prediction of the amount of noise
you predict it was a point 2 but in
truth it was a 0.1 people said you know
what let's think about this as a random
variable we can think
about
why as being a gaan because we know it a
gaan and we're going to assume that the
Gan takes on the mean that was your
prediction so we can say it's mean is
equal to the prediction you had y hat of
theta
uh and then we're going to say it has
some fixed Gus fixed variance for now
you know we can call that
K and then we can ask a likelihood
question we can do it for one pixel but
of course we could think about every
pixel as being independent because our
galaxy of noise was independent um but
let's think about one pixel at a time we
can talk about what's the likelihood
we'd say what's the
likelihood with respect to our
parameters and as you guys know now it
should just be the probability density
function of a random variable
probability density function of a normal
that's something we've seen before you
know do you guys remember this from back
in the day oh man I'm already nostalgic
we're going to have to say good don't be
strangers you guys should come say hi
whenever you see me that's not important
right now it's not goodbye yet we got a
lot of GPT to talk about before
that uh but you remember this little
expression oh man it just like makes me
sad to think that this is one of the
last times we'll be talking about
normals H okay but anyways um you have
the value of y you observed so we
observed at
0.1 we know the true mean was a
0.2 and remember this is y and this is y
hat or sorry this is y hat and this is y
for those people F
along uh and you have 2 Sigma squ so we
can say How likely does the result of
our neural network look you know or How
likely is our random variable assignment
but of course you know we don't really
think about
likelihood we like to think about log
likelihood because it's easier to work
with and if we took the log of this you
know you'd end up with a a log of this
expression you know what this thing is
going to look like a big old constant
cuz like don't
forget it's only this thing here that's
got
parameters the parameters went into
generating this number but the
parameters didn't go into anything else
so when we think about you know this as
a function of parameters everything that
doesn't have a parameter looks like a
constant so this whole thing is going to
be
log I'm going to draw a smiley face for
my constant you're like is that a Greek
symbol no it's a smiley face but it's
smiley face why CU I'm so happy when I
have to deal with constants what's the
log of this it's a going to be a
constant plus you know log of
multiplication is going to be log of
this plus log of this log of e raised to
the power of something remember exp just
means e as a base raised to the power of
cancels out what a good
time am I missing a negative no
yeah is there a negative here in the Gan
probability density function there's a
negative there's a negative yes what a
crazy time to be alive I forgot but now
but then I remembered just in time okay
so this is going be come
negative and I could write 0.1 or I
could write
y minus y hat and remember y hat was uh
something that came from our
parameters
squared divided by a smiley face you're
like you can't divide by a smiley face
oh yes I can because it's just
constant now this is all looking well
and good but there's just one other
thing I want to point us out we want to
choose our thetas to be the
argmax of this function and the argmax
of this function doesn't care about this
constant and the argmax of the function
doesn't care about this constant either
so the argmax of this is just going to
be the same as the argmax of
Yus y hat
squared that was for one
pixel and because every pixel is
independent the likelihood should have
had a big product here and the log
likelihood should have had a big sum
here and this thing would just have a
sum over here and if I throw that sum
back in I'm feeling a little bit fancy
so it's going to be
pink you get an expression that you
might have heard people talk
about it's the sum of squared errors
these are all your predictions and the
these are the True Values you look at
the difference between those two and
square it and you sum that over all of
your pixels and you're going to try and
choose the parameters that maximize this
now it's a maximum of a negative so it's
the minimize of the sum of squared
errors and so you're going to try and
choose the parameters that minimize the
sum of squared
errors it's a beautiful piece of
probability that leads to a very very
simple algorithm so going back here what
you're going to do you put in your noisy
image it goes to the neural network you
make your predictions now you have the
predictions and the truth you calculate
the sum of squared errors and that tells
you how good a job you did but that
doesn't tell you how to change the
parameters in the neural network how are
we going to change those parameters in
the neural network gradi desent gradient
descent you can't set that derivative
equal to zero and then solve for because
like there's going to be a big old set
of parameters in here but what you then
do is you just say hey there's a lot of
parameters in here for every single
parameter I can ask the question what's
the derivative of this objective
function with respect to every single
parameter oh man it's time to talk about
history I'm going to try and throw in
some interesting histories because I
can't believe I'm so old I live through
some history man my field is moving fast
so if this is
time and this is like AI
progress
I would say it has kind of felt to me
like like this and there was this huge
moment here and this was I'd say about
uh
2013 in
2013 some amazing programmer came up
with this amazing piece of technology it
has a name it was called
autograd
before that date when I made neural
networks you know what I would do I
would construct my neural network
imagine all of the neurons all the
logistic regressions connected to each
other and then me and my buddy would go
to a cafe and we'd spend our day doing
all the
derivatives and if it was a complicated
neural network you know we'd start with
the last layer then we get the
derivative of the next layer and we get
the Dera of the next layer uh we made
weird neural networks weirder ones than
I ever ever see now we'd have like trees
and stuff and it was great it was a good
time but we'd spend the entire day doing
derivatives and then there was this
great idea that started in a program
called torch which was originally
written in a language called Lua does
anyone program in
Lua one person a little bit yeah I used
to program in this thing called L it's
like a Brazilian programming language
and it was the first one that had
autograd it was such a big deal we all
learned this Brazilian programming
language named after the moon um
anyway and so what did autograd do
autograd meant that in Python I would
say here's my neural network it has this
layer this layer this layer here is my
objective
function and then I would
say automatically do all the calculus
and it would just be one line and the
neural network would know how to do the
chain rule it would know how to do the
chain rule like the derivative of this
with respect to the end layer the
derivative of that with respect to the
the previous layer and it did all the
chain rule so no one has to do
derivatives now it's important to know
that they exist and that's the magic
behind the scenes but autograd you guys
live in the future what a time to be
alive okay what that means is that as an
architect what you really need is just
this function you have to figure out
like what is the Lost function that is
probabilistically inspired so I can talk
about how good a job I'm doing and then
I can ask the computer to update the
gradients
okay wait a second that's kind of
it
insane
now in terms of the architecture here
there's a lot of things you could do but
there's one thing that turned out to be
really
important it's got to be
big and this is going to be even more
true for GPT but but for GPT there's two
things that people realize you know not
too long after autograd they're like
since we don't have to do our
derivatives what if we had a bigger
neural network and we just got more data
and people got better and better at
building special chips for doing
automatic differentiation and doing the
actual gradient ascent and people got
bigger and bigger computers and they
noticed two
things number of training time
I'm going to draw two
graphs and on the x-axis are two
different things on the xaxis is how big
are our models and on the xaxis over
here is how long do they train and
originally when I built models I would
try and make more and more parameters
but my models would kind of look like
this uh and you know I never got that
big let's say this is like 10 to the
10th
and this is like 10 to the
10th and you know my model would
eventually look like that like what does
that mean that means as I'm training it
gets smarter and smarter and smarter but
eventually I hit what we would call a
plateau and then I would call it a day
I'd go have like uh um an adventure with
my friends and I just assume that's what
would happen and for the longest time I
believed that all neural networks would
hit the
ceiling until one day somebody was like
you know what I'm just going to get a
lot more parameters and when you got to
a certain level all of a sudden people
started to escape the plateau and they
started to hit these points where it
didn't seem to have a plateau it wasn't
maybe you know getting that much smarter
that
quickly but they hit this point where if
you could just take a network like this
one put more and more parameters into it
and give it more and more data it would
just keep getting smarter and then
people did the craziest things like I
used to train these things like you guys
think about your your homework
assignment like how long do you train
your gradient descent for logistic
aggression I don't know five minutes at
most it really does Plateau out pretty
fast what you think people do
longer yeah but we tell them how many
steps to do so I okay it depends on your
computer like maybe you train it for 10
uh 10
minutes well once people realized this
they started doing something that wasn't
the most ecologically sound they're like
what if we just keep on all the
supercomputers and not turn it off for
like a year and like every time the
programmers go to sleep they wake up it
was still training and people just went
and went and went and it started getting
better and better at D noising so these
are the main narratives that led to
Dolly I hope you guys feel a little bit
like this is demystified this was a
great idea
but it's a great idea you could have
had right you know think about the
person next to you think about the
person on the other side if it's not one
of them maybe it' be you who could have
come up with this and there's many more
ideas like that out there this second
idea that was a nice one you know
instead of trying to predict uh removing
the noise just predict where the noise
is and we can do the math and that this
leads to a nice little piece of
mathematics where you know if you think
of the noise as being gussian when you
do the log likely and the argum max of
it you end up with this negative sum of
squared
errors now I'm not going I'm going to
say autograd man I'm like such fans if I
ever meet the people who did autograd I
would be like total fan booy I'm like
you guys are amazing uh and I wouldn't
say this is a great idea I think it's
just like more like okay great we can do
that all but that's kind of the big
story picture so I'm going to go
get my blue marker which is my favorite
all say that was part one of today's
adventure so I'm going to give you guys
the pedagogical pause now guess what
we're going to do
next I won't tell you I'll leave it as a
mystery take your two minutes
pedagogical pause and then we'll
continue uh today's lecture
okay I got a little Lial
my
yes
that
e
this
so what we've talked about so
far is doly and that was fantastic if I
had to name that part of lecture if I
had to give it a title it'd be Den
noising because that was really the most
beautiful idea in all of this that we're
actually going to be really creative
with our data add noise then train a
neural network that can remove that can
predict the noise and since the noise is
gaussian we've got a really nice
likelihood function we can do mle if I
had to name the next part of this
lecture I would call call it attention
is all you need because that was
actually the name of one of the papers
that led to the great idea that really
transformed
this
and you know the original GPT there
there's a lot of history here at
Stanford like the original GPT was
written by a person called Andre carpy
who is yet again also a PhD student in
Stanford so a lot of this stuff was
created by people just like
yourselves
so language presents a problem in our
previous model we dealt with generating
images but now we're going to start
thinking about language and there's a
bunch of reasons that language is really
difficult one is we subscribe so much
meaning to and intelligence to language
we take it very seriously as a society
but there's also more practical
challenges and if I could point out one
practical challenge about language is
that it's variable length you if you
think about your features
we always had a fixed length number of
features that we gave on our problem set
six when you think about GPT you know we
could control the image size it would
always be fixed size images and that
just made a lot about our architecture a
lot easier but one of the things I'm
going to point out about language that's
quite difficult besides the fact that
it's such a complicated concept is that
it's going to be variable
length so first let me tell you a little
bit about the bad ideas that didn't work
so one of the bad ideas that didn't work
so
was to build this well when I say it's a
bad idea it will be part of our final
solution they build these little neural
networks and the idea of the little
neural network would be you would
put your language through the little
neural
network and the nural network could
produce two things it could produce both
the next word so maybe you hopefully
predict
socks and it could also produce a
vector and if you took that
vector and you put this Vector into the
neural network it would hopefully
produce the next word and you could have
different words coming as inputs and so
they built these little neural networks
that you could use
recurrently you could put in you know CS
109 through this network it' produce
rocks and it would produce a vector then
you could put rocks to this network it
would produce socks and it would create
another vector and this Vector would
then become the output or sorry would
eventually become input over here so
like what you produce as output then
becomes this input and we could call
these things State vectors so you could
you have like State at time zero and one
of the things that your neural network
would make is State at time one it
seemed like a good idea and people made
language models like this for a long
time and they were fine
they just couldn't do that much they
weren't that impressive you ask for a
recipe uh and we just start like giving
you gobbley
cook on some level though this wasn't
what the really great idea
was the really great idea here was
hey let's borrow some of those ideas so
we're still going to have a neural
network it's still going to take in a
state
vector
and it's still going to produce the next
word but the great idea here is we're
going to build a very special neural
network that we're going to call an
attention neural
network and this attention neural
network is going to take in all the
words we've seen so
far and it's going to put them together
into a really really really special
format that we're going to call the
context vector
so we have this neural
network that I have not described to you
yet but what it's going to do is going
to take all the words and compress them
into some important piece of
context now let me give you a little bit
more layer of detail about what it's
going to
Output there's a lot of words in the
English
language this little neural network here
is not going to just produce a word
that's a little bit oversimplified
instead it's going to predict for every
word in the English language the
probability that that word is next so
I'm not going to try and draw all the
words in the English language but you
can imagine it creates a big old
dictionary and it'll say like
rocks you know that's pretty high
probability it's
0.001 and you could say like
Stanford maybe that's less maybe it's 10
the4 uh but for every single word we're
going to produce a
probability if I gave you this neural
network you gave me a set of words as
input it would go through the special
layer make context and start with some
random State and It produced these
probabilities how could you go from
these probabilities to picking a word
I've said a lot of complexity so I want
to take a moment and solidify I'm going
give you guys a minute to think about it
why don't you talk about with the person
next to you and the question I want you
guys to figure out is if you had a
neural network and it reduce word
probability mappings how would you
choose the next word talk about it but
also take it as a moment to figure out
what's confusing about this and we we'll
take some questions afterwards okay go
for it think about
it
e
okay an idea what would you guys do if I
gave you a neural network it took a
couple words and it gave you back this
dictionary where words with the
probability that they come next what
would you
do
you could choose the most likely word
that is not a bad idea uh and that would
be
possible but here let me just tell you
about one thing that would happen do you
remember when we had that great idea we
had like the white pixels but I said if
you did that then every time you ran
this you would always get the same image
if you choose the most likely word then
every time you write cs1 and iron rocks
you'll always get that most likely word
because because again there's no
Randomness in the neural network itself
so while that would be a good idea you'd
always get the same production we want
it to be a little bit different each
time okay yes what if you just pick a
word that's like likely enough and then
yeah like sample randomly from all the
words is it good enough and then put it
in there it is I don't know if that's
what you're going to say but sample
randomly is what people do so you get
this whole dictionary and you know what
they kind of treat it like multinomials
there's all it's like this big
it's got all these sides and here's the
probability of each outcome and they
take this
gigantic English language side Dice and
they roll it and you imagine they have
to have their arms like this cuz it's so
big and they'll get one word and it's
most likely to be the thing that has the
highest probability uh but it could be
something else but let's say for now
when you sample you get the word
rocks but you know if there was another
high probability word when you roll that
dice it's very possible you get
something other than rocks so at this
point oh
sorry ah it doesn't say rocks that's
what it just
had CS 109
rocks
socks what what did you say is great cs9
no you can't say cs9 rocks is great it's
always Rock socks like what else can you
rock and roll no it's definitely
socks
um okay so socks is the word we choose
sorry now at this point we don't want to
just produce one word we want to keep
doing this so in the same way that we
when we were doing the den noising we'd
reuse our neural network to remove more
and more noise we're going to reuse our
neural network so at this point we have
a neural network it's produced the word
socks and it's also produced another
Vector another set of neurons you know
you can imagine you can just take the
last layer of activations here and treat
that as a vector and we're going to
reuse that exact same neural network but
now instead of having C9 rocks we have
cs19 Rock socks and we're going to put
that through this special thing we
haven't talked about in detail called a
tension layer again that's going to give
us a set of neuron activations and then
we're use the same neural network that
neural network wants a state Vector it
wanted a context vector and it's going
to Output another dictionary uh and I
don't know what comes after socks can
somebody help me out here what could go
after socks be be the large language
model period yes
certainly that happens with high
probability uh so when you sample from
this dictionary you get
period and it just keeps doing that now
this idea had been around for a while
and people had tried it and it just
didn't work that well because they
hadn't figured out the magic that goes
into this little
mechanism and what they do with this
little mechanism was kind of
interesting they built a neural network
that could take in any word so let's say
you had CS
109 they built a little neural network
and that little little neural neural
network would produce a single value
called an intent work let's say that
this would
um well actually I guess it would
produce two things
um let's say this is word zero because
it's the first thing it would produce a
little embedding of the word and it
would come up with an attention value so
a number between you know 0o and
one and this little neural network it
also took the state Vector so you would
take whatever state Vector you had and
and it goes into this layer
here so we have state time Z and any
word you can put it through this second
neural network we'll call this the
attention neural network and the big
thing is that it produces this attention
Vector this context that comes out of
attention is really a simple
thing that say the context would be
equal to the sum over all the words
of the words Vector weighted by its
attention and the really simple idea
here is this little neural network is
like a focuser it would say before we
even start to process this sentence
let's have a neural network which says
what we should be paying attention to
for example when you're producing the
word socks you probably only need to
work out the word rocks it doesn't
matter what came before if you put a lot
of attention on rocks you can realize
that the next word was socks but it
might be the case that you know when you
put period you have to look and realize
what are you saying rocks and be like oh
let's put attention on this word since
this word CS 109 obviously it Rock socks
period and so it can know what to focus
on and it seems like a simple
idea but this simple idea we think was
one of the biggest changes in
architecture and then all of a sudden
people are like okay this stuff seems to
work and then again when they start to
scale up they end up with things that
could speak and create things that look
like meaning I'm almost done I know
there's a lot going on in these two
boards and I should take a lot of
questions but that's kind of the big
idea we're just missing one thing you
could get in Python and you could Define
in pytorch which is the successor of
this torch that was originally written
in
Lua and you can say I'm going to Define
all these neural networks I'm going to
just Define my States and I'll have a
neural network that takes us as input
it's kind of like you're making a tree
uh the graphical structure you make your
graphical structure and then you call
autograd you'd say I want you to update
all of these based off words where do we
get these
words the dictionary is kind of good yes
there's many words in the dictionary but
in order to do this we're going to need
a whole bunch of not just words we want
to have some like Words we're going to
make a prediction and then we want to
know was our prediction good yeah an
idea look at a bunch of written stuff
yeah they get a lot of written stuff you
know where they find all that written
stuff internet yeah not in the library
the internet's got a lot of written
stuff so somewhere on the internet
somebody was writing a passage and
they're like baze was cool but
cs19
rocked sock
like
uh fox
fox like
uh fox a
fox and someone wrote this and then
people would take this word on the
internet and they would create training
examples they would say okay I'm going
to put this into my neural network and
I'm going to see is it able to predict
this next
word the last thing we would need if we
wanted to bring this thing full circle
is not just how you use the neural
network but how you would train it which
means you need to have something like
this you need to have the
mle scoring function that we're trying
to optimize so this says CS 109
rocks we look at the real word and it's
a socks and you know what we had
produced a probability we' said How
likely it was and so since we had a
probability of socks we could use the
multinomial probability Mass function
say okay I thought socks had this
probability I can say you know what is
my last function given that
so very similar to how you did your loss
function here you know here you use the
beri loss function because you had a
class with two labels here you've got a
class with multiple labels and here You'
use your probability of one in your
berly probably Mass function and here
you use the multinomial proba mass
function and then you're done you've got
a likelihood
function and the next big idea was just
data give it lots and lots and lots of
data now to be
clear what I described is probably gpt3
it's unclear what is behind gbd4 they
say it's going to come out between
December and February they say it's
going to be as big a change from gpt2 to
gpt3 and I can't tell you what's in GPT
4 maybe they're like you know what if
instead of of attention we do retention
structure then everything works out um
who knows maybe they just came up with a
better chip that could do more autograd
more quickly
uh I'm not sure but that's the future
coming I know this is probably a lot the
first time you see it but maybe you can
appreciate that there's finite number of
things to learn there's a lot more
structure here you can appreciate for a
language it's really nice that you don't
have to do your derivatives that all
your derivatives can come for free
because there's this interesting reusing
of neural networks that gets really hard
to do the math round but computer can go
through and do all the chain rule that
you want at the end of the day you know
you're producing probabilities so mle is
still a tool you can use and this really
simple idea of I'm going to take each
input and decide how much I should care
about it that simple idea was kind of
the equivalent of noising and and it
seems that attention is really really
good in
fact this single idea was so good you
start to see it in all other places like
in algorithms that try and learn how to
drive instead of trying to do some sort
of really complicated Network now
they're trying to use attention where
they can just say okay if I can see out
my car what should I be paying attention
to when I make my next decision so this
simple attentional Network turns out to
be very helpful again autograd is a big
deal because now you have two different
neural networks with parameters all over
the Place doing lots of different
complicated things and all you would
need to do is string up your neural
network and then say computer do the
optimization for me okay questions
comments
concerns yes this is backtracking a
little but I was wondering like instead
of do in gradient asent or desent like
why can't you just solve for like the
closed form of the the log likelihood
and then find your characters that way
is it because like just too hard of a
equation yeah it is is too hard of
equation I'm prettyy sure there is no
closed form so let's talk about why it's
hard first of all if you had one
parameter you would solve take that
gradient set it equal to zero and then
solve right if you had two parameters
you have two equations two unknowns and
then
solve these things have close to a
trillion parameters so you can set up a
trillion equations a trillion unknowns
and then try and solve but I it gets
worse you know when we think about our
neural networks they're all logistic
regressions like at some point you have
the
activation of one logistic regression
cell inside this massive neural network
is going to be equal to something like a
sigmoid uh of the weighted sum of the
inputs Times by the
weights so we're going to say inputs I
weights
I do you guys notice how
the predictions we were making if this
inner part ended up being positive we
would just predict a one if this ended
up being negative we predict is zero in
your own homework but we still had the
sigmoid originally the sigmoid was
helpful because it allowed us to
interpret the result as a probability
but it turns out the sigmoid does
something else that's really important
if you got rid of that sigmoid you said
every single neuron was just inputs
multiplied by weights and you didn't put
through the squashing function
it turns out that you could have
trillion
parameters but it would still be
equivalent to if you just had a linear
system this sigmoid here makes it
nonlinear in really complicated ways it
also makes it basically impossible to do
close forms um oh I want to tell you
guys
something and you guys tell me if I did
the wrong thing how's that you're like
Chris what did you do I
know when I make logistic regression I
use a
sigmoid but sigmoid has this really
nasty
property that if you look at it um it
has
its all its values are positive it's
always between zero and one that's great
if you're thinking about an output but
if you're somewhere in the middle of a
neural network it turns out having all
of your weights have positive values is
really annoying and problematic for
really subtle reasons and so people
don't want their inner neurons to be
shifted so you could do a sigmoid and
subtract by .5 did you guys want to know
there's another
function
T anyone seen this before tan yeah the
hyperbola tangent it just it's not that
special it doesn't have a problemistic
interpretation you wouldn't use it for
the final layer but you can use it in
internal layers it looks a lot like the
sigmoid but it's just centered nicely
and it turns out this is a really big
deal if you want to have inner layers
and neural network there's other things
you can use rather than a tan but no
matter what you do sorry I went on a
tangent but you need
this you leave this nonlinear piece
right you needed to like put through
some squashing function to make sure
your whole thing doesn't end up just
being linear um it is important but it
also makes it impossible to do the Clos
form set it equal to zero
you're like here's my question I'm like
whoa tan and then we're back but I just
I need to get this off my chest that
even though we use sigmoid for the final
layer in the inner layers we actually
use tan which looks very similar but
it's centered around zero
yes the like array of parameters for
attention interact with the ones for
like the next word and the relative
probabilities for those words like is it
that you first do one and and then the
other so in the forward pass you can
imagine in the forward pass you first do
the attention on each word and what you
do on each word every word will end up
with its vector and also its weight so
you do this for every word that's your
first thing then the second thing is you
run this little function you end up with
a context at this point you have a
vector for context you always keep a
state Vector it's just always it's like
a set of neurons that are just holding
on to some
memory did you want to know what happens
here when you have to merge those two
things into this
box okay wait for it if you have a
neural network and it's getting inputs
from the top and it's getting inputs
from the side check out what we do so
these are it's just a vector a little
bit like your X's but now you've got two
of
them we do this we stack them you take
your first one you take your second one
you stick them together and now you got
one vector going into your neural
network very similar to how you have
your X's going into your logistic
regression so you know we use this this
is just a diagram but really it's these
two are both inputs into the neural
network
okay is that a question yeah exactly
what like the state one and state two
actually what makes it meaningful what
is it even story they're just neurons
they're just like you know you have
these you have some
neurons that produce values and you have
a bunch of them and then you store them
in memory and in theory it's holding on
to memory it's holding on to ideas that
it's constructing as it's going so like
maybe it's trying to produce a poem in
Pirate speak and it's producing it word
by word and it has to keep track of
where it's going in some space and it
stores in these neurons and I don't even
understand what's going on with those
neurons but it's some sort of black
magic and it just like keeps it uh so
that it can make its prediction for the
next we
it's
amazing structure this
is
sh uh yeah and you know you can
imagine much like when we were producing
images remember producing images like
you could produce one pixel and then
another pixel and a third pixel it's a
lot like that these are just a bunch of
neurons and they're Al going to be
produced a little bit like their pixels
it's just we're going to store them as
state use in a different way we're
actually
wow I was like two algorithms how long
could it take but I wanted to draw on
the board because I wanted to go slow
and go over the details and maybe if I
could leave it on this
is it does normally I'm you know I was
the person who was kind of hoping we'd
never hit general intelligence I was
kind of hoping we'd stay in like the
simple world where we just do our
educational things but uh I must say
until Thursday I was like oh yeah people
are making their gpts how cute oh my God
Dolly I can make a picture of a tree
this is fantastic and then I started
playing around this a lot over the
weekend and in my heart I feel like it
is a bit of a change and it's not such a
big change it's not like the whole
world's going to reorient around this
stuff uh but it is a new technology and
it you know what it reminds me of did I
say I was so old I remember when mobile
phones became a thing I was a computer
science major and all a sudden we have
mobile phones you can make apps and
there was a rush everyone wanted to make
an app my God I probably should have
made a map if I made an app maybe I
could have retired young not to self hey
you want to go into like a business this
we're going to do some cool GPT based
neural network no let's put in the p app
oh we'll put in the P set app and then
we'll all do it together you know and
then did mobile phones change everything
yes and no you know there was a whole
set of new ideas that came things were
possible it was a very exciting time to
be a young researcher because all of a
sudden like I was I got to The Cutting
Edge a lot faster you know when I look
at gpt3 you I've told you a lot of what
I know about gpt3 and um you know soon
you guys can be on that Cutting Edge and
I think that's a little bit exciting
it's a little bit terrifying because
there's uncertainty and uncertainty is
always hard except for people with st
probability we like to make decisions
under
certainty I don't know and I would
welcome you guys to this conversation
you know what do you guys think it means
and and where do you want to see it go
how would you like to shape it like what
role would you like to
play and then come back on Wednesday
it's our very final class we're going to
have to say goodbye I'll miss you don't
be strangers have a fantastic day you
guys rock see you on
Wednesday